what would you say to the government
employers and what would you say to the
public Dave start with you first uh I'd
say that this country more than at any
point in our history uh needs a new deal
for working people
I think we need to give workers a
greater voice in the way that companies
are run I think we should have more
people who are on the boards so that the
experience of workers and customers we
should have more customers on the boards
of companies where you provide services
um and we we need
fresh ideas in the world of work we
can't carry on and rebuild the economy
and grow businesses on the basis of
constantly playing to the lowest common
denominator it is outrageous governments
are actually subsidizing uh the pay of
them of working people because these
companies are getting away with
constantly
saying that modernization has to be that
you you have people with no problems
a big change okay up to Manchester
doctor what would you say to the
politicians and to the public in 90
seconds please
well we've got a crisis in the NHS seven
million on waiting lists serious
problems with our Workforce if you want
to solve that
um it is a solvable problem and we want
to help you solve that and we want to
talk to you about retention we want to
talk to you about pay and pensions and
you are able to stop strike action in
the Health Service if you so wish you
just have to be willing to come to Fair
deals with us on the issues that matter
to health workers doctors nurses
paramedics and across the Health Service
what would you say to politicians in the
public I would say that public services
are on their knees they were decimated
during austerity and now there's another
round of austerity on public servants if
you want people to be well educated if
you want them to be able to go to work
it's because they've got their illnesses
they've got their operations when they
need them if you want them to be
supported when their families are in
struggles and you want children social
workers and you if you want a decent
State and you want civil servants who do
the Public Services which are needed and
support Public Services then you have to
talk to public sector workers you have
to talk to workers and you have to stop
the longest squeeze on pay since the
Napoleonic Wars you have to stop that
we've had 12 years of not being talked
to we need a conversation now okay um
Eddie we started with you so let's end
with you as well what would you say to
the politicians and to the public
I'd say now's the type of change I'm I'm
with Dave Dave on this we have got to
have a change in this country we've got
to have a fear of society where people
are looked after and I mean that in
terms of wages in housing in pensions
any NHS we need a sea change in this
country uh that means the people in this
country are looked after better because
we can do it things don't have to be
like this so we need some change
and let's also talk about the fact that
the strikes are
still on at the moment we're still
waiting for junior doctors to um have uh
their votes but from what you were
saying the newsline for me is that
potentially the strikes could be called
off if you get what you a more promising
conversation with the transport
secretary so we will be meeting the
employees today we'll meet the secretary
on Friday and we're prepared to
negotiate and have planned to right the
way through the weekend into the wee
hours if we have to okay to try and get
a settlement for next week okay what do
you get when that's great we need the
company to stop attacking our members
every single day of the week and we need
them to get in the room and negotiate
what do you need uh we need we we are
about doesn't finish until the middle of
January there is time for the government
to sit down with us and negotiate and
that's what we want to do and in
Manchester what do you need
what we need is pay restoration and a
pension solution both of which are
crucial for retention okay thank you all
very much indeed for joining us on the
program